-Welcome, everybody.
Welcome, welcome
to "The Tonight Show"!
You're here!
You made it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, guys, last night,
New York Yankees superstar
Aaron Judge made baseball
history and hit number 62.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's right.
Judge hit his 62nd home run
of the season
to break Roger Maris's
American League record.
Of course,
right after it happened,
responses started pouring in.
Everyone was tweeting about it.
Even President Biden
congratulated him.
This is real.
Biden tweeted...
That's nice.
[ Laughter ]
And Biden
sent another that said...
[ Laughter ]
That was nice.
-Oh, yeah.
-Then Biden said...
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
-That's really too much
information, almost.
And then Biden said...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Wow!
-Invented baseball.
-He was there!
-He loves baseball.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow!
But listen to this.
The home-run ball itself
is thought to be worth
at least $2 million.
-Ooh.
And it was caught
by an investment banker.
-Ugh.
[ Laughter ]
Huge moment for the Yankees
and an investment banker.
What a night
for the underdogs, you know?
[ Laughter ]
Every fan of that game
last night
wanted to catch Judge's
home-run ball.
I think one guy
wanted it a bit too much.
Watch this.
This is real.
-Go, go!
Soaring into history!
-Oh!
[ Cymbals crash ]
Oh!
-Well, that's one way
to beat traffic.
[ Laughter ]
"I'm outta here."
Yeah.
Turns out the guy is okay.
He was actually caught
by an investment banker.
[ Laughter ]
He's currently worth $2 million.
Switching gears, today, in the
aftermath of Hurricane Ian,
President Biden
travelled to Florida
and met with
Governor Ron DeSantis,
even though DeSantis has been
highly critical of Biden.
It's like that special episode
of a Disney sitcom
where the school bully realizes
he needs help
with his math homework.
He's like, "Sorry
I called you those names."
But DeSantis
was actually nice to Biden.
He actually even offered him
a free flight
to Martha's Vineyard.
I thought that was --
[ Laughter ]
Generous.
Well, I heard that former
President Trump has asked
the Supreme Court
to overturn a ruling
that allows
the Justice Department to review
roughly 100 classified documents
that were seized
from Mar-A-Lago.
Trump said, "It's my
Constitutional right.
And I would know
'cause the original Constitution
is hanging in my bathroom
at Mar-A-Lago."
[ Laughter and applause ]
"I should know."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Speaking of Trump,
less than 24 hours
after announcing a defamation
lawsuit against CNN,
he sent out
a fundraising e-mail,
asking supporters to donate
$5 or more to his cause.
[ Laughter ]
You know these are strange times
when you're the one sending
grandpa 5 bucks.
You know?
[ Laughter ]
Well, get this --
in Maggie Haberman's
new 608-page book
about the former president,
she wrote that, one time,
on a plane,
Trump made it a point
to loudly complain
after Rudy Giuliani
used the bathroom.
[ Laughter ]
Maggie, if you're watching,
I think a 607-page book
that left this story out
would have been just fine.
[ Laughter ]
Apparently,
Trump yelled at Rudy,
he's like, "Have some respect.
The Declaration of Independence
is in there."
[ Laughter ]
Well, in a new interview,
Dr. Fauci said
at the start of the pandemic,
he should have been more careful
with his messaging on COVID.
Fauci was like, "In retrospect,
we shouldn't have ended
every CDC statement
with a question mark."
[ Laughter ]
But Fauci also said...
Or as Fox News reported it...
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's not what he --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, people
are talking about this.
In the new animated
"Scooby Doo" movie,
Velma comes out as a lesbian.
Even more shocking,
Fred comes out as straight.
-Oy!
[ Laughter and applause ]
Whoa!
Zoinks!
Ruh-roh!
[ Laughter ]
-Some TV news.
"Frasier" is coming back
in a sequel series,
where he'll have all-new friends
and live in an all-new city.
Yeah, on "Cheers,"
he was in Boston.
Then he moved to Seattle.
Now he's moving again.
I don't think Frasier's
a psychiatrist.
I think he's a serial killer.
[ Laughter ]
Now, get this, everyone.
I saw that the producer
of James Bond
said that the next Bond
should be an actor in their 30s.
Which means that Bond's
catchphrase is gonna sound
a little different.
Here are some options.
I'll give you an example.
Here we go.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Sorry.
♪♪
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
♪♪
[ Laughter and applause ]
Listen, these are options.
That's just what --
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's just what he might do.
-He might do that.
-He's in his 30s.
Who knows?
He might do that.
He likes the kitchen backsplash.
[ Laughter ]
You guys see this?
That's what he enjoys, yeah.
"Thank you! I appreciate it.
I got it at Anthropologie,"
yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Did you guys see this?
A painting of a woman from 1860
is going viral because people
think she's walking
while texting on an iPhone.
Take a look at this.
[ Laughter ]
The name of the painting is
"Getting a DM from Adam Levine."
-Whoa!
[ Cheers and laughter ]
-That's the part I thought --
that's the part I thought was --
that was, like, prescient.
-Maroon.
-Yeah.
And, finally, a town in Canada
just erected a roadside statue
of a giant Cheeto.
Check it out.
[ Laughter ]
Looks like they could've
erected it a little bit more.
I'm just saying.
-Ayy!
[ Laughter ]
Can we see that again?
Yeah.
The name of that statue is
"Donald Trump at the Urinal."
Hey, everyone,
we have a great show!
[ Cheers and applause ]